they are a minority but they are
angry all across the country from new
hampshire to nevada and states in
between
protesters demand the government let
businesses reopen
it's in god's hands what happens to me
and my health
and and anybody else's for that matter
now he's giving us another 15 days
and i believe after the 15 days he's
gonna give us another 15 days
and 15 days i mean come on it's insane
dr debra burke leading the white house
coronavirus effort says
it's concerning so many demonstrators
aren't wearing masks
it's devastatingly worrisome to me
personally because if they go home and
infect their grandmother or their
grandfather who has a co-morbid
condition
and they have a serious or a very or an
unfortunate outcome
they will feel guilty for the rest of
our lives the white house recommendation
to states
reopen business only after you've seen
14 days of decline in cases
despite the fact that no state has
reached that threshold
about half are loosening restrictions
and the trump administration is again
trying to turn the focus to china by
sending what seems to be contradictory
messages
look the best experts so far seemed to
think it was man-made i have no reason
to disbelieve that at this point
your your office of the dni says the
consensus the scientific consensus
was not man-made or genetically modified
that's right i i agree with that yeah
i've seen their analysis i've seen
the summary that you saw that was
released publicly i have no reason to
doubt that that is accurate
the u.s secretary of state without
providing evidence arguing the virus
came from a chinese lab
that wasn't created by its scientists
while the country weeks into quarantine
tries to come to terms with what comes
next
and at what cost patty culhane
al jazeera